comment vous avez perçu ou vécu les
propos du député David guireot en
Tunisie le même weekend ù où en fait il
justifie les horreurs commise par le
Hamas en accusant à Israël de faire la
même chose très mal très mal parce que
ce sont des erreurs factuelles des
erreurs historique et et un et un
discours qui est qui est profondément
inacceptable je je crois que bon la
chose lui a été dite chose lui a été
diteuel pas refuse de le sanctionner ça
il y a il y a une
il y a un problème à la Direction de la
France insoumise il y a besoin d'avoir à
à mon sens un sursaut là un sursaut
éthique j'ai l'impression que leur
boussole je sais pas c'est c'est c'est
déboussolé voilà elle elle ne marche
plus donc il y a besoin que les insoumis
voilà se ressaisissent fassent du commun
dans l'unité et je sais que c'est pas
simple parce que c'est vrai n no nos
contradictions nos oppositions sont
aujourd'hui publiques et ce n'est pas
simple à articuler mais il y a besoin de
de de ce sursaut vraiment j'appelle
j'appelle la direction de la France
insoumise à déjà faire le son propre
bilan il y a un an lorsque cette
direction s'est autoproclamé entre entre
guillemets elle a dit attendezil y en a
que pour un an on fera le point à la
prochaine assemblée représentative en
décembre là on y vient je objectivement
leur bilan est mauvais et et puis il y a
des il y a une sorte de voilà une sorte
de de gêne j'ai moi j'ai une gêne donc
en ce qui concerne
d pardon une gêne à être encore dans ce
parti avec avec avec la dire vous voulez
absolument me mettre en marge du parti
quel gêne ma gêne par rapport à à la
position qui a été prise par la
direction et notamment manuel bonpard
c'est pas que je ne la partage plus
c'est que elle c'était pas notre
position je ce n'était pas notre
position moi j'ai l'impression dans ce
cadre là d'être une insoumise en ne peu
plus banale et Canal historique voyez
j'ai pas du tout l'impression que c'est
moi qui a bougé j'ai pas du tout
l'impression peut-être que je me trompe
mais mais j'ai l'impression d'être
d'être solide sur mes assises et mes
principes qui sont ceux qui constituent
mon
engagement dans dans cette
organisation